[Music]  [Applause]  why would i betray we all have our  secrets we just didn't get to yours yet  [Music]  the world is arming faster than we can  respond  where's double-oh-seven  I need a favor brother you're the only  one I trust for this  the world's moved on commander bond you  would double Oh two years so stay in  your lane you get in my way I will put a  bullet in your knee  [Music]  one that works that's what you two would  get along named Vonda  James Bond so you're not dead  hello Q I missed you  it's the most valuable asset this  country has if you feel yourself losing  control I'm not gonna lose  control  James you gave up everything for her  [Music]  when her secret finds its way out  there'll be the death of him  what is it you don't know what this is  James Bond license to kid history of  violence I could be speaking to my own  reflection only your skills die with her  body mine will survive long after I'm  gone history isn't kind to men who play  God  [Music]